one of the biggest comics in the country
thinks the woke mind virus killed comedy
Conan O'Brien is blasting the way his
fellow liberal late-night hosts handled
the Trump era the way he explains it
instead of trying to be funny they were
more interested in pushing a political
agenda I was never as comfortable with
comedy where I needed to make a point
about something so I always thought that
that when Trump came along what a lot of
people have to revert to is doesn't he
suck I hate that guy
and those aren't jokes and so I I think
it's just
um you know I'm really going on a limb
here saying that's his greatest crime
that he's I think he's hurt political
comedy by being so outlandish himself
and Bill Maher is no stranger to taking
on the woke mob the left-wing comic is
also taking a swipe at his late night
competitors for pandering to Liberal
audiences is that a take those guys
don't have takes I have takes I have a
take on things what they do is say
exactly what a liberal audience wants
them to say about that
that's not a take I'm not I mean I'm not
saying it's not sincere I guess it is on
their part but even if it wasn't that's
what they would do there's never a
moment where you don't know exactly oh
this is the correct point of view on
that
Mark just announced that his show will
be returning despite the writer's strike
and that's not sitting very well with
ultra liberal blowhard Keith Olbermann
he's trashing Bill Maher as a quote
scumbag for bringing his show back all
right Greg I think you're the natural
first on this one as a fellow late night
host the Conan and Mark do you agree
that the focus on Trump is pretty much
destroyed comedy yeah and also Richard
Nixon destroyed the art of juggling
you know
worked up because that's the only work
he's getting here's the bigger issue
here with all of this
with comedy or anything or this show you
have to participate in all parts of life
not just the click or or the bubble or
the sect that you're in and I think that
was their big mistake they turned their
back on half the country because Trump
made them cry and over words not Deeds I
mean what what Conan said that the most
outright outlandish crime Trump did was
his behavior not his deeds the economy
didn't matter the fact that there were
no Wars didn't matter but did you see
his mean tweet I can't sleep that's not
funny my Show's successful because we go
at everything including not just my
guests like peers who's on tonight but
also me I'm my biggest Target and that
we hold everybody to the fire and it's
amazing that in the this is the funniest
time to be alive I mean we talk about it
later tonight about wokeism is like the
biggest funniest thing ever but Joe
Biden is a perfect Target Hunter's a
perfect Target Nancy Pelosi the city's
descent in this criminal farce is a
target climate change wackos gender
Nazis all of this stuff is ripe for
comedy but to these guys it's Trump or
it's nothing and I and instead they're
actually you have comedians that are
actually crying on air or doing
propagandizing videos for vaccines
that's why I think late night is in a
chaos except here the knives are out for
Fallon they're going after Bill Maher
because I think he's doing the right
thing he's doing the right he he's
saying we are hurting all of these other
people the Caterers you name it whatever
because you're the writers are upset and
meanwhile you got these other
dingleberries these other hosts you know
they're doing they're doing Zoom calls
together like they're doing a staff
meeting during covid I mean how pathetic
is that I think I like Conan but uh he's
a little late to this party we've been
talking about this forever uh a typical
it takes him three years to figure
things out whether it's you know
education crime or immigration whatever
we're always waiting for them to catch
up they're like your simple little
brother
don't you have a simple little brother
I'll go tease him a little brother I
would never see this
I mean look they're pandering that the
left is pandering to their political
audiences and they don't have actual
takes according to Bill Maher so do you
agree with him or well I gotta say well
ironically one of the funniest things
I've heard actually in years is Keith
Olbermann describing Bill Maher as
selfish and unfunny and a scumbag it's
coming from a guy who in my personal
experience of years of interacting with
Keith olberman is not only a selfish
little
yeah also deeply unfunny possibly the
unfunniest person in America and
indisputably a massive scumbag so uh
there's irony there but no I think look
we were talking about this on Greg's
show tonight
the truth is the material about the woke
crowd is obviously hilarious right it's
funnier than anything else out there you
can't out funny Trump he's what he wants
to be he's funny in all of them put
together
um but you take like the violence for
example just the material around the
bikes I speak as a British person here
okay it is objectively hilarious to see
that you ran 250 years ago you ran our
monarchy out of town you said Mad King
George packing right and now because you
didn't like the way he ruled you and now
you have a guy in charge who keeps
falling over
who everything he says makes no sense
who can barely remember what day it is
and I simply say to you Prince William's
flying into New York on Monday it is not
too late America it is not too late
because if you think what you've got Now
is better than what we gave you and the
Mad King George you are living in Cloud
Cuckoo Land Bring Back Your monarchy
I'll even pitch my own hat into the ring
and honestly could you be any worse than
under this fast it is a fast I look at
Joe Biden I think America how are you
letting this happen and the idea he runs
again yeah and it runs again for another
four years of this it's ridiculous so my
point to the work comedians is there's
your comedy every single day you should
be leading on this stuff but they can't
because they're trapped in that mindset
that this is actually what you're seeing
with your own eyes is not happening
they're blind to the reality which is
comedically funny but also for Americans
deadly serious
that's my point okay all right well
we'll all run over to William Prince
William now he's going to be staying up
there you can get him back in the King
William of America only if he dumps that
broad no no he's a good guy
um
you Brits all look alike
all right you know Jesse if it weren't
for Trump these people wouldn't have
anything to talk about where would
comedy be now with this woke group what
happened was Colbert came in at CBS and
he came from The Daily Show so he had
those John Stewart chops and he was a
natural political guy and then he came
in and his ratings went up and Kimmel
said oh my gosh I have to start getting
political and Kimmel loved Obama and his
son had a little health issue and he
started getting into these little things
with Ted Cruz and then he became a
political guy and Fallon is the least
political guy out there and resisted
going political and is also the most
talented but then was pushed into
politics by Executives he didn't want to
go political and so all of them go
political and then Trump leaves the
pandemic happens and then there's the
writer strike and then someone named
Greg Gutfeld comes along and all of
their
audience of the king of late night Their
audience is looking around like what
happened where are all the jokes and the
jokes are nowhere because they can't
poke funded by it now if you think about
Biden this is a guy who went to Maui and
said you know what I had a kitchen fire
and I almost lost my cat this is a guy
whose son is in his underwear with a
cocked gun and a stripper this is Kamala
Harris Kamala Harris's husband kissed
the First Lady this is Mayor Pete
butterjudge he puts a little helmet on
in a reflecting vest and goes to East
Palestine there is a wealth of jokes in
this Administration the administration
is a joke but if you could just kind of
lay off the politics you could bring it
back not that Greg wants it back but you
could bring it back
Shannon do you see the entertainment
industry recovering from this I mean and
being actually funny again and
non-political what I love that's funny I
think is that they found a way to blame
president Trump for for their industry
falling apart
um I do think comedy that's super
obvious no matter who the target is is
really not that funny you got to think
it through like Greg does he got to have
you know five steps ahead playing chess
with this stuff this is like my birthday
yes we love you okay Greg but I think
about okay for me Babylon be hilarious
it's satire that gets checked by
fact-checking sites which to me is
satirical in itself that they do this
but they actually have a section of
their website called prophecies
fulfilled where they've made up such
ridiculous stories that have now
actually come true in real life so you
know when it hits close to home
um and it takes a little effort to put
it together I think that's much funnier
than the obvious one-two Punch Yeah the
political punch hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
is you will not get it anywhere else